The World of Shadows It's the most dangerous disaster humanity has ever faced.Let's settle the matter,
Boromianapol.We'll
kill you and put an end to this damn hell.Everything in
this world is about to be covered in a black mist.What's
going on
inside the fog?  There's no way to know what's going on. The
only thing I know is that
no life can survive in the eroded land. I
consider my comrades who fought alongside me to be helpless. There are
too many in this hell.  The
magic pattern analysis has been completed. All the dragons'
spells have been sealed. The only way to save the world is to
conquer the world of shadows before the erosion continues. Has it come
this far? What am I doing?  [
Music] It's probably a
lie.
Familiar people, familiar places, a world from the past.
[Music]
How do you know my name? I
'm Plum Schneider from Beta class. I
won't let that tragedy happen again. I'll
rebuild this world.
[Music]